it's not really just the Iraq war it is
how are we is as the wii United States
of America Americans who are right now
situated is the most powerful country in
the world we're never as powerful as we
think on the other hand we're pretty
powerful how is the most powerful
country in the world actually going to
demonstrate leadership as we move from
nation-state to a more globalized world
in which those boundaries we can build
all the walls we want those boundaries
are going to be more permeable than any
human being and human community ever
could have imagined them and that's very
unnerving and how to function in that
environment without a kind of without
simply returning to a kind of primal
flight fight response